let's play a game your entire
search and browsing history has been
loaded into a bot that will send it to
everyone in your contacts list
in one hour every time you stalked your
crush
every time you googled your own name
every time you asked webmd about that
weird thing on your foot
all of it will be exposed the only way
to prevent this from happening is to
find the secret message hidden somewhere
in this video and then leave it down in
the comments below
five words stand between you and
embarrassment for life all marked with
this symbol
the clock is ticking friends the choice
is yours
live or die happy hunting
internet welcome to film theory the show
that cuts straight to the truth like a
hacksaw through an ankle today we're
gonna be talking about the saw franchise
which is something i view much
differently now than i did when it first
came out back then i was all like oh man
i wonder if i'd be determined enough to
saw off my own foot to survive nowadays
i'm more like huh
that saw's looking pretty rusty hope he
got himself a tetanus booster in the
last five years but i gotta admit i have
a ton
of respect for the saw movies doing
things that no other horror movies do
and i'm not just talking about crushing
people's heads between blocks of ice
friends i mean when i watch a horror
movie there are plenty of things that i
can expect again
nightmares anxiety underwear stains but
you know what i don't expect to get team
building exercises seriously before the
saw movies came out had anybody
ever heard of an escape room not only
did this franchise make me horrified of
fluorescent lighted bathrooms in need of
a good deep clean but it also doomed
many people to the fate of solving
lightly thematic puzzles with
acquaintances from around the office
the other rare thing that the saw
franchise did was to give us a super
villain with
reasons behind what he's doing jigsaw's
stated goal in the movies is to make
people more appreciative for being alive
and to motivate them to stop doing
whatever terrible things that they're
doing in their everyday life
you see the knowledge of death changes
everything if i were to tell you
the exact date and time of your own
death
it would shatter your world completely
you savor everything be it a glass of
water or walk in the park
but most people have the luxury of not
knowing when that clock's gonna go off
the irony of it is that that keeps them
from really living their life
which is weirdly admirable in a way
certainly more admirable than michael
myers who just wants to kill because
he's crazy or freddy krueger who wants
to kill you for fun
or leatherface who wants to kill you
because he needs your bones for
furniture i mean don't get me wrong here
what the jigsaw killer is doing is
twisted and gross and
seems like an engineering nightmare but
i don't know he's like a motivational
poster
a bloody bloody murdery motivational
i've never murdered anyone in my life
the decisions are up to them alright
john
sure you didn't kill anyone saying
you're not a murderer because the traps
kill them is the same thing as shooting
someone and claiming you didn't kill him
the gun did nice try buddy rationalizing
away your horrific murder spree aside
the saw franchise does bring up an
interesting point
is jigsaw right is putting people into
dangerous painful
life-threatening and ethically
paradoxical circumstances leaving them
better off
assuming that the players of the games
actually live through them which is
usually not the case well let me tell
you after doing the research
jigsaw isn't wrong and today i'm here to
tell you why
so sharpen your hacksaws stay away from
pits full of needles and steer clear of
any tricycle riding puppets cause today
we're diving deep into whether jigsaw is
through his own twisted psychology
making the world
a slightly better place now the first
saw movie came out in 2004 when the most
cutting-edge game you can get on a cell
phone was snake
so even if you're a fan of the franchise
you might need a refresher on jigsaw aka
john cramer's motivation so here's a
recap in your official spoiler warning
for the entire franchise in the original
saw movie jigsaw kidnaps two men adam
and dr gordon and give some cryptic
clues on what they have to do in order
to escape the grody bathroom that they
awaken in but as the movie goes on we
slowly learn why jigsaw chose these two
for his game
he finds them both morally objectionable
adam spies on people and sells his
photos to blackmailers and dr gordon
appears to be ignoring his family to
have an extramarital affair but it's
when we see a flashback to one of
jigsaw's surviving victims that we get
the real motivation behind his games
amanda
a drug addict finds her head in a
reverse bear trap that threatens to flip
her skull
inside out unless she finds a key to it
in a dude's intestines remarkably
she succeeds and is then given the
creepiest end screen of any game ever
congratulations you are still alive most
people are so
ungrateful to be alive but not you
not anymore so jigsaw is teaching his
victims little life lessons to help him
realize that they are hashtag blessed
and it works for amanda after this
traumatic ordeal she overcomes her
addiction telling the police
he helped me jigsaw's goal is ultimately
to help people turn their lives around
which mirrors his own journey as we find
out in later movies
jigsaw is a guy named john cramer who
got a double dose of bad news when his
wife miscarried their unborn son and he
was diagnosed with terminal cancer when
he survives an attempt to end his own
life he becomes determined
to testing the fabric of human nature by
teaching others that
those who don't appreciate life do not
deserve life
in short he wants to almost kill people
so that they'll snap out of their bad
behavior
or you know they just fail and die
though to be fair john if this was truly
your stated goal
you would give them i don't know a
little bit more than 60 seconds to
dislodge the key that was surgically
implanted behind their eye to remove
them from the spiked iron maiden that's
about to snap their head in two
just saying obviously it's all a
psychopathic idea right
you can't play mousetrap with people's
lives but for as
crazy as jigsaw's logic is it's not
without precedent throughout history
many philosophers
have seen trauma and suffering as a
means of achieving personal growth such
as schopenhauer kierkegaard and most
notably
friedrich nietzsche with his catchphrase
that god is dead and that luxurious
mustache nietzsche rode the line between
emo and hipster better than any other
19th century german philosopher and he
was famous for not being all sunshine
and rainbows in his thinking in his 1886
work beyond good and evil nietzsche
presents a couple of philosophies that
jigsaw would likely
retweet on twitter nietzsche claimed
that society
evaluates actions based on intention
rather than consequence and he's right
about that because society's laws are
generally based on intention let's say
that there's a burglar roaming around
your neighborhood so to protect yourself
and your neighbors you drop an anvil on
its head wiley coyote style the law
would say that your intention
was to harm someone and therefore your
anvil drop was immoral
and more importantly to you a ruling of
murder nature would look at your action
and say that because its consequence was
good
i.e people not being robbed of their
jewelry and electronics and pokemon
cards then the action would be a moral
one
in other words nietzsche believed that
the ends justify the means and that an
action with positive consequences
is moral regardless of its motivation or
execution
nietzsche is saying that the results are
what really matter in determining the
right thing to do
someone who sees the same burglar and
calls the police or
warns the neighborhood might have a
purer intention than the anvil dropper
but those shouldn't be considered
because their consequences are less
effective the police
might not arrive or they might let the
burglar go and commit future burglaries
warned neighbors might still get robbed
but if you smush that burglar on the
sidewalk like a pancake you can be sure
that he's committed his last burglary
and therefore
nietzsche would consider it the most
moral of the choices
because its consequence no more
burglaries was the most
certain then he'd lean back in his chair
and comb that epic 19th century mustache
of his jigsaw
presumably agrees given that he
considers himself morally righteous in
playing these games he figures that if
some people can be saved or
improved as a result of the torture then
the torture was the right thing
even more importantly nietzsche believed
that progress was the result
of suffering specifically he wrote this
quote the discipline of suffering of
great suffering
don't you realize that up to this point
it is only this suffering which has
created
every enhancement in man up to now that
tension of a soul in misery which
develops its strength has that not been
given to it through suffering
through the discipline of great
suffering again to translate that from
cranky german philosopher to english
nietzsche was saying that all of
mankind's progress is the result of
suffering and therefore we should
embrace it
well if that ain't jigsaw to the letter
i don't know what is if mankind's
greatness is the result of suffering
jigsaw figures he can just add more
suffering into the mix and create better
people as a result
okay so jigsaw studied some philosophy
to impress people in college we've all
been there
or at least i've been there because i
studied kantian philosophy in college to
impress my now wife stephanie which
worked i guess i don't know it was the
only class that i ever skipped it was
senior year and just a bonus class that
i was taking to fill out my schedule
also in my defense still got an a anyway
just because some of jigsaw's principles
are rooted in the thoughts of great
philosophers doesn't necessarily mean
he's right
do his games actually change the
survivors for the better
surprisingly yes it was the best thing
that ever happened to me he was abusive
but it wasn't until that moment that it
really did something
well to be fair most of the players wind
up dead a shocking number of survivors
wind up with a new
outlook on life it's something that the
series deals pretty heavily with in saw
3d
during a group therapy session for
survivors of jigsaw's games we hear that
many have found themselves a new outlook
on life
i am simply here to illustrate the fact
that a traumatic experience can
have a positive outcome but if you look
around at all of these people
taking their lives for granted
eventually they all
found something positive from their
experience heck both
amanda and dr gordon from the first saw
movie not only survive but also end up
adopting jigsaw's philosophy
helping him set up his games with new
participants in future films
so some philosophers agree with jigsaw
many of the surviving victims of the
movies agree with jigsaw but does the
science
agree with jigsaw i suppose to convince
you you need some real world evidence
that the kind of trauma jigsaw subjects
his victims to
actually has benefits well let me
introduce you to richard tadeshi and
lawrence calhoun
psychologists and creators of the
post-traumatic growth index
in studies conducted in the 1990s
tadeshi and calhoun set out to see if
they could measure the positive impact
of disasters in people's lives
whether that was being diagnosed with a
terminal illness being a victim of
violence or
surviving a natural disaster and the
results for the survivors of these
traumatic events
were positive survivors self-reported
positive change in the direction of
their lives
overwhelmingly 80 said that they had
established a new path for their lives
and 76
reported that they were able to do
better things with their lives a
separate study compared survivors of
trauma to those who had experienced no
major trauma the results found
that the survivors outscored the control
group in terms of their ability to
relate to others
personal strength and most importantly
for jigsaw their appreciation of life
all in all
60 of participants expressed that there
was a positive effect on themselves
after the trauma so that kind of means
jigsaw is right doesn't it trauma's
messy to be sure but science shows that
overwhelmingly it leads to improvements
in people's perceptions of themselves
and their lives
the victims in the movie agree ye oldie
philosophers agree and science agrees
that's it theory over slapping on a
thumbnail we're done with another
halloween season upload
except for one thing john kramer didn't
read himself the fine print
this is why i always gotta read past the
headlines people because
while yes sixty percent of participants
expressed a positive effect
after the trauma a whopping 94
said that they experienced either some
or extreme
negative consequences as a result of the
trauma estimates vary but
experts believe that people who
experience some acute form of physical
trauma
have between a 20 and 50 chance of
developing acute stress disorder and or
post-traumatic stress disorder both of
which often manifest in nightmares
flashbacks increased likelihood of
self-harm sure if you survive a plane
crash you might appreciate your life
a bit more and not get bothered by
little things as much decide to take
that improv class that you always wanted
to but you're also much likelier to
suffer panic attacks and have your daily
routine more interrupted so it's pretty
short-sighted to say that introducing
trauma into people's lives will only
help them and you know what
jigsaw of all people should understand
that
because most of his trauma was damaging
to him
rather than helpful after he lost his
unborn son
his response was grief and depression
not wow
my life is suddenly better when he was
diagnosed with cancer
more grief and depression not sunshine
and rainbows
it took him a third trauma the
near-death experience of ending his own
life for him to have his quote-unquote
epiphany but the whole situation should
have told him that the typical result of
a traumatic event is not some positive
life-affirming change it is insecurity
it is depression it is grief it is
post-traumatic stress
turns out that maybe we shouldn't be
looking to a serial murderer for
philosophical and psychological guidance
who knew in the words of one of his
former survivors
you want to know the best thing that
happened to me after having to cut off
my
own arm his handicap parking at the damn
mall everyone's a critic i guess but hey
that's just a theory a film theory
and game over
you